hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker -
I have not calm down I have not gone
easy on myself and as you can see I'm
about to get a whole lot worse but
listen to my logic listen to me I'm not
getting the satisfaction I need out of
it by feeling like I accomplished
something even though the multiplayer
was super weird when I want it
I felt accomplished I felt good about
myself I went in with a positive
attitude in the next thing so I should
try to hit something really hard and
then if I win I'll feel so good about
myself you know what I mean I'll feel
really good but if I fail I will feel so
unbelievably bad and if I don't manage
to get through this all even in the 30
lives I have I'd feel terrible right
cool
this one's called underoos I don't know
why ooh
where am I going with this what that's a
big wiggler that's a big wiggler oh wow
[Music]
I didn't do that I didn't do that okay
so so far so weird but you tricky you
tricky well hi just ah alright you
weren't tricky about that one but I'm
still gonna blame you al brosse now go
hey I don't need your charity I am a
good gamer okay no tricks here
I swear I don't need your 1ups anymore
okay what is this Oh Oh interesting
interesting
r'ragh interesting interesting found a
secret oh oh oh wait wait oh wait oh
wait oh wait by way hang on a second
Oh give me you down here Oh who needs it
not me not me I don't need that as
stupid for dumb people unlike me oh hey
you're there okay here we go oh there we
go
so I just got to make it in this little
gap between him and nevermind it's
impossible okay okay that's not fair
that's not fair that's not fair okay
there you go and I'm here
okay I'm going fast I'm going fast Oh
going so fast
can you please there we go all right I
need to go smack on those assets okay
let me up here all right it's not what I
was hoping for how how am I supposed to
do that huh how do i conserve my
momentum do i like run up against the
other wall after i oh god no no not like
no there's not enough it's impossible
[Music]
I jump on you that is the secret that is
what I do I gotta wait no it's not bad
maybe I don't
maybe I don't young maybe jumping is not
the right answer
some may suspect they jumping is often
well god damned you I think that maybe
I've got I know what to do I go here and
dad using my hair I was wrong I feel
such a surging sense of accomplishment
oh yeah go baby here I go like thundered
bottle blood and I'm gonna know what all
right here I go baby here I go like
thunder I'm gonna jump on you okay all
right okay here we go
sorry I just went in a fugue state I
almost Walter whited my way through the
rest of my life but I don't think it's
gonna this was a good idea this is a
good idea this is a good idea
oh my god Mary oh come here yeah
all I gotta do all I have to do is jump
on all I gotta do is jump on this thing
it's gonna be perfect cuz now there's
all blah there's a block oh yeah I
forgot that hidden blocks is No
okay I'm the only one who have died
there apparently I gotta get on that
block I can do that and I did it see
easy peasy let me up there let me up
there let me up here where am I
is there danger abound what's up what's
down oh I see what you got going on oh
no use
[Music]
so I tell us comfy huh
I know your game now oh I know your game
now tell me how when I bought that block
it block Smith down to the bottom of the
bumper tell me how that right in
comments how when I bump on the you big
bouncy sack of tip okay here we go again
all right back on the saddle oh my oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god what am i doing I know I'm not
supposed to go here but here I am okay
so what I gotta do I gotta go here boink
on that end and up here and then oh yes
I will take it I will take it I think I
needed that I needed to do it there's a
checkpoint there is joy and love in the
world nah my cuz I got a checkpoint that
makes me feel better that makes me feel
better
I feel good the sense of accomplishment
is almost here guys it's always here
there's nothing there for me I did it
again I did the same thing that I did
before again I did the same thing is the
same thing the same thing I'm gonna go I
can't go up your ass so why did I think
I could I will venture forward you are
my bear
I will let you know when I am done to
sky my face in his match did you see
that we both had the same face the face
of pure outrage oh I'm going to get you
I am going to get you I am going to get
you you can't stop me from giving you I
am going to give you I am going to get
back here so I get there we go
and you know I didn't even need that
[Music]
here's-here's the sense of
accomplishment that I sold you guys
power it's that sense of accomplishment
alright CIN CIN if that is your name
sidan city why am I out of time or it
was just crap that's what that was but I
can wall jump now it's good to know I
don't like what's up with this what is
this about wait hang on wait but that
looks oh yeah that's what that looks
like I've never seen that before which
is why I was a little suspect ative of
what that was also I know that I'm in
the devil's Playhouse made
I don't even know if I need these reds
but I'm getting them anyway wig skews
[Applause]
Mario did you crave the sweet embrace of
death boy do I know the feeling
but next time give me some warning
that'd be great
I'm gonna why must be accidentally
pressing the down button which is the
best button with which to do that
maneuver so of course of course it is
the best of course because what else
would you do let's go for ride you are
moving too quick I don't like the speed
that's not what I was hoping for either
last chance all aboard the last chance
and here we go and I'm alive I'm dead
[Music]
again I feel so good that I accomplished
that one level that was what I was
hoping for this this deep yearning sense
of accomplishment which I feel I do feel
I feel it I can't pronounce your name
but I'm sure you're good at making
levels here we go that's a friendly moon
right there now that's a print oh it's
great this level feels good feels good I
can't get this for some reason but it
feels good alright yeah you know maybe
it's not so bad
Oh Oh give me that moon again that's
that's what it felt good not whatever
else is happening here okay
come here you hand come here you yeah
okay that's a bit of a welcome but all
right sure what am i doing wait what am
I don't don't don't just send me here
without letting mean what am i what am i
trying to accomplish here oh don't
okay all right this is okay this is fine
hey guys I think everything's gonna be I
did it and you know what I feel good
about it I feel good that I did it
that's all right
you all right cool and oh I almost did
the thing I almost didn't think oh yeah
that's the best I'm okay you're dead oh
[Music]
all right you know maybe this ain't so
bad after all
this feels really good okay oh okay all
right
Oh
[Music]
yeah hey moon how you doing I feel so
good when you're around I just feel like
everything's gonna be okay yeah you're a
dancing moon you're so cute
give me a little bit of you yeah you you
make my day bright full life love full
of laughter give me a rum there we go
like a dream easy
got it uh well didn't get that but
that's okay got you okay you you're not
gonna get me though huh all right we
have fun here I'm gonna get this and
then you're gonna get dead because I'm
gonna kill you ha ha this is great okay
well that was an option that you didn't
have to take but you did so I guess I
can't fault you exactly for it oh yes
that's what I'm talking about
finally the recognition all right well
you okay well I don't feel good about
what happened oh god no no are you you
you must be joshing
okay oh I don't need it I know the way
to speed through another way to speed
through this I know the way I've been
showing the way the way is written on
the inside of my eyeballs the way has
been shown on the inside of my eyelids
if I just close my eyes and feel feel my
way through I'll make it to the end
I missed it turns out closing your eyes
doesn't work
turns out closing your eyes the way was
not written on the insides of my eyelids
it was just kind of dark watch well I
know this is this is possible this is so
possible oh I almost made it but that
hammer is a little bit problematic I got
you because the Hammers of Rando I know
they are
oh you're gonna get me with that hammer
every time aren't you
all right fine you want to play like
that huh well that's okay cuz I've got
an insurance policy for things such as
you I'm still gonna do this mind you but
now I know
oh so that I almost got you I almost got
you got this just like that baby just
like that easy as pie hos okay so I just
gonna you know incus oh come on yeah let
me join kiss it you gotta let me join
kit you Inc you let me you ain't kit I
just want to join kit chance a man join
can peace
[Music]
okay well purple msyn good blurple I
like Miss Marple guys I know that this
ain't the smartest way to do something
but I have never mmm I've never been the
smartest about doing things I do things
my way and my way says to go this way
and it is oh and the way is good
oh and the way is good you winking oh my
god
your IQ you throw off my joint you throw
off my yonk stop old that's why that
it's a prop just wanna say I love you
here comes the young king junking
incoming link why am I not using my
phone well cuz I don't have it anymore
apparently
why did you grab that and not go no
listen guys I know if I took my time I'd
be able to get through it with more
certainty but I don't care that's not
what I can I physically can't be patient
at this moment so I have to do it my way
or it will in fact be the highway this
is where the muscle meets the hustle
where don't you get off my block okay ah
wait I may have made a drastic most
calculation okay I may have
miscalculated something it's yeah yeah
nah maybe I got it maybe I got this
maybe I got this oh boy
man I don't like you guys boy boy there
I go there's that goes OH
where'd that bone come from wise god
damn it just let me go No
I need to hit the block I guess I guess
I have to yeah that makes sense I guess
no there's got to be another block
hitter over there I will not even when
show even when shown my way is
impossible I will not falter
that's what bravery is oh come on
I was hitting that one why did I get
dabbling then why did I get dabble is
diff you made me take the average why
did you make me dab you dare run with me
oh oh yeah well not today
not like that I just want one sweet cool
victory okay so there's got to be like
some kind of yeah oh there there how do
I hate you what how do i I did it good
get dead dad die die die die die die no
no don't you die don't you dare don't I
hate you so much
I oh my god I hate whoa I hate oh my god
I'm gonna go for this red if you any of
you if any of you here we go no not like
this don't let me die
not like this let me die let me die
I've got this there are so many of those
little bastards we did it guys we're
dead I mean okay hey yeah yeah yeah yeah
I feel so accomplished oh wait hang on
wait wait wait guys no no no I'm alive
yeah what Oh what was happening what is
that
I don't know what's happening I didn't
know no I thought I might be done but
turns out my nightmare is still
continuing come 10 Ewing everyone oh how
do you do
odo I'm sorry for what I've clearly done
to you deserve whatever I do apologize I
am very sorry I have clearly wronged you
in so many ways I wish would not punish
me there is no I didn't mean to do that
but there is no way so what does it
matter it matters not for it is just my
fate here I go into death ah there's no
way there how there's very clearly no
way die just swear I'm a broken man I
have my only chance was with that fire
flower and now I am a broken man broken
beyond all sensibility there is no way I
am oh so I can fit in that gap but it
doesn't matter the mall of the story
here is just don't try why bother you're
only going to be upset everything is
awful and hey we're all gonna die at the
end
of our existences thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want more great
content coming at you hot and heavy why
we ring the bell hey Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing bong bong there's a bell down there
for you why don't you ring that thank
you everybody summer for watching if you
want more let me know and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
I am dead inside
[Music]
you